now when it comes to covert 19 vaccines
south africa has an adequate supply but
it's proving tough to get jabs into
people's arms some are put off by the
long journey to vaccination centers and
others are worried about the side
effects so far just under 10 million
people have been fully vaccinated
against the virus that's less than 25
percent of adults in the country
in the hope of reaching those in rural
areas one organization has set up mobile
vaccination clinics dw's adrian kriesch
has more
it's payday for social grants in the
town of tula maharashi hundreds of
people have traveled in from surrounding
villages the province of pumalanga is
one of the poorest in south africa
and also has one of the country's lowest
vaccination rates that's why health
workers have set up a mobile vaccination
site right next to the queue
it is easier for me when i can get
vaccinated at the same place where i
pick up my social grant they only came
once to my village to vaccinate and i
only learned about it when it was too
late that's why i'm happy i can get it
here today
mobile vaccination sites are being set
up next to welfare offices and
supermarkets where grants are paid out
all over the country the idea take the
vaccine to the people
so in the course of today about 700
people over 60 will collect their grants
we know that people over 60 are far more
vulnerable and far more exposed to
covert and severe consequences from
covet so it was an obvious thing to come
to the queue where older people are
collecting their grants to offer
vaccines because they are already in
town at a place where they are easy to
find and approach and offer the vaccine
less than one in five people in
impumalanga have been vaccinated so far
many people here haven't been vaccinated
because they live in rural areas it is
expensive and difficult for them to
reach vaccination centers
it's not just access to vaccination
that's stopping people getting the jab
there are other worrying reasons says
elizabeth eduard she's been researching
why people in cape town are reluctant to
get vaccinated people's religious
beliefs are one issue she has ideas on
how to combat this
if religion has been pointed out in a
particular
population
then
what would be recommended is what i'll
call or what is generally called the
stakeholders engagement engage religious
leaders opinion leaders community
leaders and
for social media
that's a tough not to crack
those waiting for their social grants in
pumalanga have also heard many rumors
about vaccination side effects but
carlos marwanga isn't worried he says
all his friends who got it are doing
fine
well for more on this i'm joined by
ashraf khajii he's a professor in the
department of psychology at stellenbosch
university thank you very much indeed
for being with us here on dw news africa
now despite the covert 19 vaccine being
available to all south african adults
why is the uptake so low
there are a range of reasons we should
keep in mind that the task of
vaccinating the entire adult population
in a very short space of time is quite
unprecedented usually government
vaccination drives have been targeted at
infants and children and travelers and
there's never been a need to vaccinate
adults on such a large scale because
there's never been a pandemic of this
nature in living memory
the the second thing that i want to say
is that usually people believe that
contact with the health system
is necessary only when they become ill
and so it does require some kind of
psychological shift to accept that a
well person who requires a vaccination
to remain well those are a couple of uh
uh initial reasons but i think also
whenever a new concept or technology is
introduced into a society not everybody
is going to rush at once they'll be
innovators there'll be early adopters
there'll be an early majority and what
we now need is the late majority to step
up and make themselves available for
vaccination okay so could you talk us
through some of the social norms and
behavioral elements that play a part in
this vaccine hesitancy that we're seeing
yeah so the research on social norms
tells us that people's behavior
is often influenced by their perceptions
of what is normal or typical in other
people
so if people understand and believe that
most other people have accepted a
vaccine then there's a strong likelihood
that many other people will follow but
of course this is uh required in the in
the context of information that vaccines
actually save lives
so how do you convince people to take
the jab when there are challenges around
convincing them to do so we need to
counter vaccine
hesitancy we need correct information
based on the latest research we need
easy access to vaccination sites so
vaccination sites should be where people
are taxi ranks train stations
where where farms are uh close to
places where people actually are to be
found in large numbers we need visible
social marketing campaigns and community
champions who encourage acceptance of of
vaccination
so
for example the congress of traditional
leaders of south africa has called on
men to take the covet 19 vaccine because
relatively lower
numbers of men have been
accepting the vaccine compared to women
also religious leaders who have a huge
amount of influence among their
congregation they should continue to be
role models in accepting a vaccine
and then other prominent community
members celebrities sports men and women
health workers elders to
publicly accept a vaccination and
encourage others to do the same all
right
ashraf khajii thank you very much indeed
for your insights